about to fix it if your financial
situation has changed
we may be able to help
[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef to the
stars of the football gridiron
jamaican immigrant darian bryan has come
a long way from his island roots
while it was there that his passion for
food and cooking was born
it was here in the states that it grew
and developed the 29 year old brian is
now a personal chef for a slew of nfl
players and other pro athletes
and they're not the only ones craving
what this young chef
is serving up here we go
what's your eyebrows chef darian brian's
personality
is as much a part of his meals
[Applause]
as the food itself
you always tell people when you book me
you just don't get the food and you get
the entire package right the swag you
know
you get it all isn't she lovely
it's a swag brian was born
the only boy in a family of six kids
raised by his mom in jamaica
he learned to cook by her side
eventually taking over her cook shop
a takeout place at age 15 when she moved
to the united states
five years later brian followed settling
in buffalo new york with one of his
sisters
how does a guy from jamaica end up in
buffalo
so my story is i have an option to
choose either california
or buffalo i want to experience some
snow you know
i always see it on tv i want to actually
feel it
touch it and build a snowman so after
the first two years
in buffalo i'm like you can take this
snow back man
it was rough snapper steam jamaican
style
as was brian's transition to american
life
most notably american food coming here
i didn't know what a bacon was nor
pancake or no anything like that
your first job was at denny's right
flipping pancakes
you learned very quickly what a pancake
yeah yeah i learned very quickly what a
pancake was
at the same time brian had enrolled in
culinary school at erie community
college
where he encountered similar hurdles we
call
avocado pear in jamaica and people that
get me that avocado i'm like what's
avocado is this in front of you i'm like
i don't know that's a color
i disappear did i no that's avocado this
is so much for me to learn
did it make you more determined oh yeah
i just didn't want to be the average guy
you know
i have all these ideas written down
already what i want to do
when i'm out of my own place one day so
i need to know all of these stuff
so i gotta go to the process step by
step
so he got a bachelor's degree in
hospitality management to go with his
culinary arts degree
then worked his way up in the buffalo
area restaurant scene
but it was a chance encounter with then
buffalo bill's cornerback vontae davis
that propelled brian even further this
restaurant i was working at
me walking i was like surprised to see
you know you don't really see black
folks in the area you know so i'm like
oh okay
so i was talking to him this wasn't you
as a bills fan saying here's a bill's
play no i didn't know who he was
so i want to know who he was you know we
were just talking i saw him the next day
is that everything was amazing man who's
in charge i'm in charge
and he's like i want to be my chef and
that was it i was his personal chef
the first of about 15 pro athletes that
brian has become a personal chef for
including current bill star stefan diggs
and while he's expanding their culinary
palettes
he's also taking a page out of their
playbook
my model is redefining a chef
i want to take them from the back of the
house bring them to the front
we're just as the importance of the
athletes you know we
take raw ingredients and create
something magical you want people to see
who created the mask yeah i want to see
the
the excitement in your face when they're
eating that steak or whatever it is
which is why he launched the plating
society brand
wearing his signature fedoras brian
cooks for both his personal clients and
catering business
and for the past two years he's been
front and center
at pop-up restaurants when i first came
here
i saw you bought your cooking i'm like
man this is awesome i would love to do
something like this
so i keep on telling my wife jessica and
she said there's pop-up shops
where you can do pop-up restaurants
today's the day man
pop-up restaurant so what we do is we
partner with small businesses i got my
big
giant friend here right and get their
space except tables and chair find that
in style
and i cook for like 50 people and two
small burners
two little burners eight course menu
as for his food when we sat down to talk
it was with some
signature dishes to taste the tomahawk
steak oh my gosh
it's beautiful it's beautiful it's like
an entire car right i think is huge
that colossal tomahawk steak and lobster
tail
hand seared scallops with bourbon bacon
jam
rice and beans and a creme brulee
cheesecake
and my buffalo soldier ah
of course you're adopted home really no
matter the dish
brian says the essence of the food is
love
something he learned not in culinary
school
but cooking alongside his mom what does
she
think of what you've created now
sometimes she cries she's like
i know you want to do great things all i
ever want to do is just make her proud
because i know the struggles you've been
to
and i just want to make my mom proud
sometimes it's tough like man
i gotta keep going though because my mom
not living the life
i want her to live i get so emotional
talking about it sometimes because it's
like it's hard man
so i'm like i'm trying to set the
foundation for me and my family
especially my mom
i want her to live the life that she
deserved because she
she ventured like with all of us
brian's latest project working on a
brick and mortar location for the
plating society which he hopes to open
later this year a space where he can be
front and center for private clients
small groups
and then bring that swag which is
exactly what he has
thank you for your service to bill's
mafia
appreciate it we appreciate it great how
about that the tomahawk steak and
scallops
delicious with a bourbon bacon